one more thing before we go from
medicine to music one doctors using his
voice to help patients and tired
hospital staff but he's not the only one
that's doctor Elvis Francois he's an
orthopedic surgery resident in Minnesota
but his uplifting songs have a much
broader reach videos of his performances
with colleagues have been viewed
millions of times online Vlad duthiers
shows us how the doctors latest song
from John Lennon is offering strength
[Music]
for dr. Elvis Francois the collective
struggle the world is facing is an
opportunity for the world to come
together to overcome the pandemic the
only way that we 7 billion of us say we
are here together as one and for this
Minnesota doctor surgery and songs go
hand-in-hand there's a lot of anxiety
there's a lot of fear and you know from
video whenever I've had those moments in
my personal life music has always been
something that I've found I've been able
to gravitate towards in the sorts sort
of brings things to ease and ease
Francois hopes to share with millions of
people through the power of music
something he believes has the potential
to heal anything medicine you know I've
found you know you goes only so far and
surgery only goes so far but you know
music those places that medicine can't
go when I can see people from all walks
of life taking care of a person to make
sure we stay in that person's life
that's hopeful to me and so I think as
long as I see that I can't ever lose
hope someday
[Music]
nice that's awesome
music heals too it really does that was
really awesome I'm looking at the doctor
voice career biceps what doesn't he I
think I'm feeling everybody yeah is
there a significant other inquiring
minds want to know